I think it's important for people to
take notice about climate change because
it is important for our survival it's
important for everyone's life I want to
do something now before it's too late
and that's why I'm doing this
documentary quite frankly the issue that
I'm exploring on my episode is the
rainforest and the rainforest it's
something very personal to me because
the largest part of the rainforest is in
my country of Brazil and I feel like
it's my responsibility as a human being
to bring awareness to something that I
feel is vital for our existence and I
feel like it's the most precious natural
resource this forest is providing a
stable life for all of us in the planet
so I think is everyone's problem
in my job as a model I've always been
very protective because I never really
allow people to put out my voice and my
job is very much a visual thing you know
it's like a picture and it's a frame and
people make assumptions based on that
image but now it's like vulnerable for
me because I'm coming out with something
that actually is personal to me
natural resources are not infinite you
know there's only so much land there's
only so much water greed is an
unfortunate trait of human race and it's
about short-term thinking instead of
long-term understanding of the natural
process of things so sad to see like
this
I mean anybody should know this I mean
it impacts all of us keep being
destructive we're not gonna have great
quality of life that we are used to